nos libera de tener que renacer.
Es una idea muy fuerte:
se liberan de la vida tal y como la conocemos.
Esto es lo que atrae a millones de personas.
Y para albergar a tanta gente, se levanta una megaciudad.
Durante los 55 días, 7 millones de personas viven en el lugar,
y los otros 100 millones lo visitan.
Estas son imágenes del mismo sitio
tomadas en las 10 semanas que demanda la construcción de la ciudad.
Luego del monzón,
las aguas de estos ríos comienzan a retirarse,
los bancos de arena quedan al descubierto
y el terreno está listo para construir la ciudad.
Y para el 15 de enero,
es decir, entre las semanas del 15 de octubre al 15 de enero,
emerge una ciudad entera,
una ciudad que alberga a 7 millones de personas.
Lo fascinante es que esta ciudad
tiene todas las características de una megaciudad de verdad,
cuyo trazado se hace sobre una cuadrícula.
El sistema urbano se basa en esta cuadrícula,
y cada calle de la ciudad
cruza el río sobre un puente flotante,
sumamente resistente,
para que, en caso de una lluvia fuera de estación, o si el río altera su curso,
el sistema urbano quede intacto.
La ciudad se adapta al terreno, el cual puede ser inestable.
La ciudad también replica toda forma de infraestructura
tanto física como social:
abastecimiento de agua, desagües cloacales, electricidad,
1400 cámaras de circuito cerrado para garantizar la seguridad,
monitoreadas desde una estación instalada a tal fin.
Y la infraestructura social
incluye clínicas, hospitales,
todo tipo de servicios para la comunidad,
que le dan el funcionamiento de cualquier megaciudad.
La ciudad contrata 10 500 barrenderos.
Hay un sistema de gobierno, el Mela Adhikari,
o la comisión del festival,
que garantiza el permiso para usar el terreno,
la gestión de los sistemas,
para que todo en la ciudad, la movilidad, todo funcione correctamente.
Les diré algo: fue la ciudad más eficiente y limpia
en que viví en la India.
(Risas)
Así se ve la ciudad si la comparamos con Manhattan.
Son 30 kilómetros cuadrados.
Es la escala de la ciudad.
No se trata de una ciudad informal ni improvisada.
Es una ciudad formal, un emprendimiento estatal.
Es una iniciativa del gobierno.
En el mundo actual del neoliberalismo y del capitalismo,
donde el Estado ha delegado toda la responsabilidad
de diseñar y construir ciudades,
este es un caso increíble.
Es una ciudad deliberada, intencional, formal.
Y, además, está asentada en el terreno con estructuras ligeras.
Está en las orillas de estos ríos.
Y deja una huella ínfima.
No hay cimientos.
La construcción de toda la ciudad se basa en telas.
Otro detalle increíble
es que este asentamiento se construye con cinco materiales
para albergar a 7 millones de personas:
bambú de 2,4 metros, cuerdas o sogas, clavos o tornillos
y materiales de cobertura, como metal corrugado, tela o plástico.
Al reunir estos materiales, funcionan en conjunto
y actúan como piezas de ensamblado.
Su funcionalidad puede abarcar desde una pequeña tienda de campaña,
donde se pueden alojar cinco o seis personas, o una familia,
hasta templos con capacidad para 500, e incluso 1000 personas.
Este concepto modular e imaginativo de la ciudad
permite su desmantelamiento.
Así, finalizado el festival, en el curso de una semana,
la ciudad se desmonta por completo.
Vemos de nuevo imágenes del mismo sitio.
El terreno vuelve a pertenecer al río,
cuyas aguas lo cubrirán con la próxima llegada del monzón.
Este concepto modular e imaginativo permite no solo el desmantelamiento,
sino también la reutilización de los materiales.
Por ejemplo, los postes de electricidad se llevan a pueblitos del interior,
los puentes flotantes se usan en pequeñas ciudades.
El material se reutiliza en su totalidad.
El concepto es fascinante, maravilloso.
Ahora bien, uno puede adherir a estas creencias hindúes o no.
Pero es un ejemplo extraordinario,
digno de reflexión.
Para que esto sea posible, la gente pone toda su energía e imaginación,
sabiendo que el proceso se revertirá,
que la ciudad será desmontada y desaparecerá.
Es una megaciudad efímera.
Y nos deja profundas enseñanzas
sobre cómo evitar el impacto en el terreno,
sobre la reversibilidad,
sobre el desmantelamiento.
Sin duda increíble.
Y lo cierto es que, como humanos, nos obsesiona lo permanente.
Nos resistimos al cambio.
Es un impulso común a todos.
Y nos resistimos al cambio
aun sabiendo que quizá el cambio es lo único constante en la vida.
Todo tiene fecha de vencimiento,
incluso la "nave espacial Tierra", es decir, nuestro planeta.
¿Qué podemos aprender, entonces, de este tipo de asentamientos?
'Burning Man', claro está, es mucho más pequeño,
pero se basa en la reversibilidad.
O los miles de mercados callejeros que abundan en todo el mundo,
en Asia, América Latina, África, el que estamos viendo en México,
que los fines de semana dan vida a terrenos de estacionamiento vehicular,
con 50 000 puesteros que trabajan de manera temporal.
El mercado de agricultores en el continente americano
es un fenómeno increíble, donde se crean nuevas químicas.
Se extiende el margen de espacios que no se usan, o no de manera óptima,
como los estacionamientos para vehículos.
En mi propia ciudad, Bombay, donde trabajo como arquitecto y urbanista,
este es el paisaje que veo a diario.
La llamo "la ciudad cinética".
Se mueve como un organismo vivo. No es estático.
Cambia todos los días,
siguiendo ciclos a veces impredecibles.
Unas 6 millones de personas viven en estos asentamientos transitorios,
como, lamentablemente, los campos de refugiados,
los barrios pobres de Bombay, las favelas de América Latina.
Aquí, lo temporario se está transformando en lo nuevo permanente.
Aquí, el urbanismo no se trata de grandiosos proyectos,
sino de grandes adaptaciones.
En las calles de Bombay, durante el festival de Ganesha,
ocurre una transformación:
se levanta un edificio comunal que permanece en pie 10 días.
Allí se proyectan películas de Bollywood,
y miles de personas se reúnen para comer y celebrar.
Está construido con papel maché y yeso blanco,
y diseñado para ser desmontado.
Al cabo de 10 días, desaparece de la noche a la mañana,
y la calle regresa a su anonimato.
O nuestros maravillosos espacios abiertos, llamados 'maidans',
que se usan para este juego indio tan sutil, complejo y fascinante
llamado críquet,
inventado, creo, por los ingleses.
(Risas)
Y por las noches,
una boda se celebra por fuera de la cancha.
Observen que la cancha no se toca, por ser terreno sagrado.
(Risas)
Pero los miembros del club y los invitados de la boda
comparten la cena a través de una cocina en común.
A la medianoche, se desmonta
y el espacio vuelve a la ciudad.
Aquí, el urbanismo tiene una naturaleza elástica.
Quiero entonces que reflexionemos sobre estos aspectos.
Se me ocurren varios interrogantes.
Pero uno muy importante es el siguiente:
en las ciudades que habitamos, en nuestra visión urbanística,
¿estamos dando soluciones permanentes a problemas transitorios?
¿Estamos encerrando recursos dentro de paradigmas
que ni siquiera sabemos si serán útiles dentro de una década?
Considero que esta es una pregunta interesante
que surge de esta investigación.
Observen los centros comerciales abandonados en América del Norte,
en las zonas periféricas.
Los expertos en comercio minorista predicen que, en la próxima década,
de los 2000 centros comerciales actuales,
el 50 % quedará abandonado.
Una cantidad enorme de materiales que captan recursos
que al poco tiempo se dejarán de usar.
O los estadios olímpicos,
construidos en todas partes del mundo
a pesar de las controversias por el uso de inmensos recursos.
Y cuando los juegos terminan,
en general, esos recursos no se reutilizan.
¿No podrían ser estructuras nómadas, transportables?
Tenemos la tecnología para hacerlo.
¿No se las podría ceder a otras ciudades del mundo o de los mismos países,
o almacenarlas y luego reutilizarlas en las próximas Olimpíadas?
Es un uso inconmensurable e ineficiente de recursos.
Como el circo.
Es decir, pensémoslo como un circo:
esa maravillosa institución que se instalaba en las ciudades,
y entablaba ese delicioso diálogo visual con la ciudad estática.
Y adentro, se desplegaba el asombro.
De pronto, niños de distintos grupos étnicos se congregan en un mismo sitio,
gente de distintas razas se encuentran,
grupos étnicos y culturas diversas se dan cita para compartir el asombro
de un espectáculo donde participan animales y artistas.
Se crean nuevas químicas cuando la gente toma consciencia de ciertas cosas
y luego se repite cuando el circo va a la ciudad siguiente.
O los flujos de la naturaleza, el cambio climático.
¿Cómo enfrentamos este desafío? ¿Cómo podemos adaptarnos mejor?
¿Es posible crear sistemas urbanos más ligeros,
o vamos a agredir permanentemente a la naturaleza con infraestructura pesada,
algo que ya estamos haciendo, con pésimos resultados?
Ahora bien, no propongo
que debamos construir ciudades a semejanza de un circo,
no propongo que las ciudades deban ser totalmente transitorias.
Tan solo estoy exhortando
a la necesidad de cambiar nuestro concepto de ciudad,
de destinar más espacio
al uso de recursos en una escala transitoria,
un espacio donde usemos nuestros recursos de modo eficiente
con el fin de posponer la fecha de vencimiento del planeta.
Hay que cambiar el concepto de planificación urbana
para dar lugar a lo temporal, lo reversible, lo desmontable.
Este cambio puede tener un impacto inmenso en nuestra vida.
Cuando pienso en el Kumbh Mela
al cual asistí con mis alumnos,
y el momento cuando la ciudad fue desmantelada,
una semana después del festival,
no quedó marca alguna.
El terreno esperaba a ser cubierto por las aguas,
a ser consumido.
Y fui a agradecer a una suma sacerdotisa
que nos había ayudado a mí y a mis alumnos con nuestra investigación,
facilitándonos el proceso.
Fui a verla con gran entusiasmo,
y le transmití lo mucho que habíamos aprendido
sobre infraestructura, la ciudad, la eficiencia de la ciudad,
la arquitectura, los cinco materiales utilizados para levantarla.
Me escuchaba con alegría, con una sonrisa.
Luego se inclinó,
me puso la mano en la cabeza para bendecirme
y con un susurro al oído, me dijo:
"Siéntente bendecido porque la Madre Ganges
les ha permitido sentarse en su regazo estos días".
Varias veces reflexioné sobre sus palabras y, claramente, comprendí su significado.
Quiso decir que las ciudades, la gente y la arquitectura van y vienen,
pero el planeta debe seguir existiendo.
Tratémoslo con cuidado, dejemos una ínfima huella.
Es una lección fundamental para los ciudadanos y arquitectos.
Y creo que esta experiencia me ha convencido
de que lo transitorio es más importante que lo permanente
y más importante que nosotros.
Gracias por escucharme.
(Aplausos)